the description
I hope everybody's having a great
Wednesday thank you so much for joining
us all today for the demo and thank you
Ryan for the great demo
um I guess we could kick things off by
just introducing ourselves over here now
that we're we're in the Q a portion I'm
Rachel Dempsey I'm our Pro Community
manager here at posit and I host a
variety of different community events so
it's so nice to see you all here
um Ryan you want to introduce yourself
again yeah so I'm Ryan I was a guy whose
voice you just heard for the last 30
minutes I'm a data science advisor here
at posit and just really pumped to have
this kind of live interactive session
where we can answer any questions you
had about all that stuff I talked about
or any positive questions happy to help
and then we're also joined by my
colleague Dave and I'll uh him to
introduce himself hey I'm Dave grenwald
I'm a manager in Solutions engineering
um and I'm also here to help answer any
of your technical questions around Corto
or otherwise looking forward to it
awesome and thank you all again so much
for joining us here as a reminder there
is a slido link open where you can ask
questions anonymously too and it's just
shown on the screen here
um but we can copy it over into the chat
right now as well
but you can also ask questions just live
in YouTube and I can pull them up on the
screen
and so one of the questions that was
asked a bit earlier
um during the demo which I thought might
be helpful to to cover is
what exactly does pinning data mean
yeah and I can take this one so pins is
something I use all the time and the way
I like to think of it and kind of the
way the package is named pins I think of
it like a sticky note or a piece of
paper you walk into your office and you
pin that sticky note or piece of paper
to a board and your office and then your
colleagues can walk by they can see that
piece of paper they can interact with it
they can use that piece of paper so it's
a great way to take any object you've
created in r that could be a data set
like we did today it could also be a
model any other object or object you can
also do this in Python so definitely if
you're a python developer you can still
pin data and it allows you to take that
data and pin it to a location a board
that can be connect like we did today it
could be another location and it allows
your other you know your future self and
of your colleagues to incorporate that
pin data set into their workflows so
rather than for example maybe you have a
shiny application and if you're
deploying it to connect you might have
to kind of include that data with the
application education that bundle but if
you use pins you can just publish just
the code and the shiny application can
reach out to that pin and Pull It in
automatically so you don't have to kind
of attach that data set to the
application itself
yeah pins is great it's a really good
tool for building out some powerful
workflows
thanks so much Ryan
um I was just going to cover a quick
question about the demos themselves so
we host these end-to-end workflow demos
once a month so the last Wednesday of
every month at 11 A.M Eastern Time
and so
if you had received an email from us or
if you saw it on social posts or maybe
on LinkedIn you may have seen this link
here on the screen on POS dot i t slash
team demo and that will allow you to add
these events to your calendar
and because it's a new demo each each
week that link is in actually updating
but it will send you to the playlist of
all of those demos so when you add that
to your calendar it will send you to the
end-to-end workflows demo playlist and
you should see three there
um right now that you can go back to and
you can view that content too
but thank you for the question about
that in the chat too
so another question that I see over in
YouTube right now is from Darren
and Darren asks is blastula still
recommended as the package for
customized email reports
yeah Dave do you want to take that one
or you want me to take it sure so so
with connect you can still do that
scheduling and you will get an email but
if you want to do that customized kind
of whether it's an HTML email or more
conditional formatting that's where
blasula still is our preferred method
but again whenever you do set up a
Content that's deployed to connect you
will get notified when that is Rerun so
if you just want to know that your
content is available connect does that
by default but if you want that more
customization blastio is a great way to
do that
and just and to follow up there as well
I I was talking to some of our core to
engineers and this is a functionality
coming to quarto very soon so stay tuned
awesome thank you
okay so another question
uh let's see
so one one question from earlier that we
didn't get to cover yet in the chat was
is there any advancement in allowing
python variables and Cordo uh markdown
text the way R can
yeah so at the moment uh it it we do
just support the uh inline execution
with r uh having python is on the road
map but uh at the current version of
quarto we we just have the inline
execution of all our code
great thank you and I'll copy a few
questions over from slido as well sorry
I forgot about that for a second but a
question over um on slido and thank you
Tim was our chordo themes compatible
with PDF output at this time
yeah I can start with that question and
Dave you can certainly add any other
color to it but the great thing about
quarto and creating custom themes is
that you can choose how to build that
theme for a specific output so if you
want to for example for the demo today I
created a simple theme that really was
tailored to an HTML output but if I
wanted to I could create a custom theme
specific for a PDF output or both so
that's kind of like the power of being
able to customize your own themes that
it's totally up to you your choice your
organization
uh only thing I'll add is with PDF there
are some features that won't translate
one to one from HTML to PDF so just be
aware that you might see some nuances
that that emerge but uh for the most
part we did try to simplify that as much
as possible
great and I see Heather had asked over
on YouTube
and that the HTML file of the quarto
report would be attached to a scheduled
email is it possible to have the body of
the email include the themed quarto
content
yeah I think that's um kind of relating
back to that blastula question we were
talking about so if you do want that
HTML content like those plots those
tables that you have inside a quarter
document actually embedded in the email
then you really want to for right now
consider using our markdown with
blastula but this functionality is
coming very soon to Corto as well so
stay tuned for that
great and I just put the link to
Flashlight package in the chat as well
um and so another question that was from
a bit earlier
um that I think Rebecca asked but I like
to keep a Titan unambiguous link between
code and output which I do in rstudio by
including code in the markdown but
connect keeps the tight link between
source and published
so is there no need to do that
hmm
Dave any thoughts on this one
uh I might need a little bit more uh
expansion on the on the question
um I'm I don't want to assume I I know
what you're trying to uh yeah and feel
free to put
um some more context in the YouTube chat
and then we can go back to to that
question too
yeah
okay one other
question I saw in YouTube is
our orcas workbench and connect is there
a benefit to investing in teams Beyond
adding package managers
yeah I can start with that one so pause
a team again as a reminder it's a kind
of a bundled offering of our three
professional tools so two which looks
like this user has workbench and connect
and there's a third one called package
manager which does essentially as its
name implies it helps control manage and
also organize and distribute all those
open source R and python packages your
team uses it also allows you to host any
internally developed packages your
team's working on
so I would say for the context of this
question you know adding package manager
it rounds out that team offering
um and so that's something important to
know and I would consider you know I
would suggest talking to your kind of
your sales representative here at posit
because in terms of how licensing works
there's actually a major advantage to
adding package manager to pause a team
but our tools are modular as well some
teams get a lot of value out of just
connect so I'm like just workbench some
like just package manager but they all
play very nicely together and that's why
we kind of offer this rounded kind of
compiled offering a posit team
thanks Ryan um and I I just wanted to go
back to the question about running
um python inline code because we had a
little bit of a issue with transferring
people over from the demo to the Q a
um would you be able to just cover that
again yeah yeah certainly so uh if if
you're familiar with our markdown you're
able to do in-line execution of code for
r
that is a feature that is included in
quarto it's on the roadmap to get python
but at this time it is not currently
supported uh there would be roundabout
ways of doing that with reticulate
although I might say that we would it
would be much simpler once we get that
python inline execution to actually work
thanks Dave and I just wanted to remind
everybody that if you want to ask
questions anonymously you can do so
using the slido link on the screen but
you can also just ask questions directly
in the YouTube chat and then we can copy
them over to the screen
um
but while we're waiting for a few other
questions to come in I also wanted to to
add that if you are curious to learn
more about
posit workbench connect or package
manager
or you just want to talk one-on-one
instead of in this this demo environment
and Q a
um please feel free to to schedule a
time to chat with us you can use that
link I just showed here on the screen
and I'll copy it over into the chat
sometimes it's just really helpful to
note or to reach out and know if other
people across your company are already
using our tools as well I know sometimes
in huge organizations it's hard to know
who has access to what tools across the
organization so I just wanted to add
that there as well
and again we also have a series of demo
resources for you which will have some
follow-up information as well as a blog
post coming out today which walks
through the exact workflow that Ryan
went through which you can use to follow
along with in the recording too
it looks like there's some questions
about comparing quarto to our markdown
especially if you're an R developer so
just to reiterate from the YouTube
channel uh comments there was questions
of like is our markdown going away uh no
uh we are still supporting our markdown
that will be continued support uh Corto
I think the advantage there is that
there are additional features it is
easier to switch what that output output
looks like whether it be a slide or a
report even Dynamic content or PDF word
docs even Confluence now so there's a
lot of additional features that are in
quarto on top of being able to very
easily work with python or other
languages that you might experience and
that way you're a little bit more in a
non-r Centric platform uh whereas our
markdown has to run within an RM
environment quarto runs outside of an R
environment that can run R within it so
there's a little bit of technicality
there but I think that does open the
door for those multilingual teams that
we do see
yeah and add on that as well like you
know in a lot of ways you can think of
Corto as like our markdown 2.0 but it is
our way of bringing our mark down
essentially to anyone if you're a python
developer if you're a Julia developer if
you're an observable developer you can
create a quarto document and one of my
the coolest things about Corto is that
the way it's designed it's actually can
support data science languages that may
not even exist today
um so in 10 20 50 100 years from now the
landscape of data science could look
completely different there could be new
languages that are at that Forefront of
data science and we expect quarto to be
around during that time can easily work
with these languages as well
thank you so much
another question that came in over on
slido is can scheduled reports access
secured data sources safely
yeah I can start tack on that one as
well but one of the benefits of using
posit connect for your job scheduling is
that you have very very tight control
over who has access to this content and
also know who's getting these emailed
reports as well
um and so when this you know quarto
document is scheduled to run on posit
connect there may require access to a
secure data set maybe a username and
password maybe an API key or some type
of credentials and connect makes it very
easily easy to supply those credentials
to that piece of content so it has that
privileged access to gather that content
so
short answer yes
thank you
so copying over just another question
over on slido was
all right just copying it over so it
will show on the screen in the demo did
each day's rerun of the report overwrite
the previous day's report
yeah great question so when I clicked on
that box it said publish kind of the
output after it reruns
um you know essentially there's going to
be new data when that report reruns
they're going to be a new HTML output
and that will basically publish on top
of the previous version but what's
really nice about connect is that
actually keeps track of historical
versions that you've published and you
can always revert back to a previous
version or download that previous
versions bundle so you can reproduce a
previous version of that report so by
default yes it will kind of build on top
every single time you uh publish a new
report
and that actually answered one of the
other questions too so is there a way to
save the previous report
um
and in Connect can you just explain how
you access those
yes yeah so as a publisher as the owner
of that content there'll be an option at
the very top kind of close to those
access controls we were talking about
before that allows you to basically
access Source versions right and you can
select and see all the various versions
of you that report that you've published
you can easily click on it and then
download it and so that's probably the
easiest way to get access to those
previous versions
thank you Chuck had a question over on
YouTube was any advancement in the near
future for more customization to quarto
PowerPoint renderings beyond the current
use of a few Master slides
so there's there's active development on
all of the different types of quarto
outputs at the current state uh we we
still if you're using Microsoft
PowerPoint you would need to create a
few Master slides but we are continuing
to expand what type of output we do
support so just be on the lookout for
quarto updates in the near future
yeah we're putting a ton of development
effort into quartet right now we're
super excited about this tool so these
are all great questions and things that
our Engineers are currently thinking
about
yeah I will definitely share this
recording with the Cordo team as well
um another quarto
question is would it be possible one day
to give an HTML file instead of
index.qmd for blog websites or books in
the chordo yaml
it's a good question Dave do you have
any thoughts on this I I truthfully
don't know this um but I can do some
follow-up and see if we can uh find the
answer here apologies
yeah and there's some um
additional context
in the chat as well and we can follow up
and and put some of the Q a with the
recording perhaps
okay let me double check I think we have
covered all the questions over on Fido
let me scroll through YouTube
if there is a question that you had
asked earlier and we just happened to
miss it feel free to just copy that over
again in the YouTube chat just so I can
see it
I'm gonna give people a few more let's
say one minute here and see if there's
any other questions
but I wanted to say thank you so much
for for joining us today for the demo
and thank you for jumping over here to
the Q a if you do want to join
this demo again they're every sorry
almost at every Wednesday the last
Wednesday of every month at 11 A.M
eastern time and you can use this link I
just showed here
on the screen to add it to your calendar
and it's going to point you to the
playlist of all of the end-to-end data
science workflow demos so you can see
the past two months there as well
I also have a blog post coming out today
which we'll walk through this specific
example
that you can use to follow along with
the recording as well
um I did also just want to say before I
say goodbye here if you would like to
join us tomorrow
um I host the data science hangout here
at posit which is an open space for us
all to just get to chat about data
science and what's going on in the world
of data across different Industries
every week we feature different data
science leader from the community and
tomorrow will be our kind of season
finale before our July break and Joe
Chang posit CTO and first employee the
creator of Shinee will be joining us as
our featured leader and so you can check
out the data science Hangouts
at the link I just put in the chat here
but thank you all so much Ryan and Dave
anything you'd like to add
no thanks all for joining us it's been a
lot of fun yeah really appreciate the
participation here thank you all yeah
thank you all so much again if you have
follow-up questions that you didn't get
a chance to cover here or something you
want to cover in more detail feel free
to use that link to schedule some time
to chat with our team as well we'd love
to talk with you
have a great rest of the day everybody